hey Phil want a fish burger oh sure
thanks this is great um why don't I make
you something all right we're gonna make
boba Mofo's famous honey walnut shrimp
burger we start off with a 100 all
shrimp Patty no fillers we fry that up
until it's golden and juicy and so
fragrant with that shrimp flavor King's
Wine bun this is like the best sandwich
bun we use a honey Wasabi Yuzu Mayo we
got candied walnuts on there and red
onions and pickled jalapenos this
sandwich was kind of inspired by Japan's
McDonald's every burger and also wanted
to just bring in and mix it with a
traditional Chinese dish so that's what
you get you ready for this I'm ready for
this
oh that's a genuine reaction right there